yo whats up guys today I'm going to show
you how to get a gold gun in in the
extinct mode in ghosts so first thing
you're going to need to get is a assault
rifle I guess an SMG would work but this
all ref is going to be like easier now
you're going to want to go around the
sides of the map all the outside and
stuff and you want to find yourself an
attachment while muzzle brake or rapid
fire thing goes leone's at work they
change the appearance of the gun you're
going to want to find another one I
found to muzzle brakes that made it
pretty easy you find another one and
keep swapping them out they change the
skin of the gun and you see I got gold
there but I'm like I didn't really
notice it so I just kept going and tell
you I gold again let me go get gold so
you got a cold again bro yeah so you
keep doing it skin changes and boom you
got yourself a gold weapon now this
technically should work for SMG he's not
sure about shotguns or snipers or
anything else so you guys hope you
enjoyed and pisa